y, en general, a las personas que les hacían frente.
Había pasado un tiempo cuando descubrí que uno de mis compañeros,
con el que había estado compartiendo todo este tiempo,
era un supuesto violador serial.
Así que lo primero que hice fue leer un montón de artículos sobre el tema.
En enero de 2018, leí un artículo de sus presuntas víctimas,
y una de las cosas que me impactó cuando lo leí
fue el miedo de las víctimas.
Estaban aterrorizadas.
Les habían colocado cinta a las cámaras de sus teléfonos
y de sus computadoras personales.
Lo que más les preocupaba era que, al ser él un 'hacker',
podía piratear sus cosas y arruinarles la vida.
Eso las llevó a permanecer en silencio por un largo tiempo.
Yo estaba furiosa.
No quería que nadie se sintiera así nunca más.
Así que hice lo que usualmente hago cuando estoy enojada:
mandé un tuit.
(Risas)
Escribí: "Si eres mujer y fuiste abusada sexualmente por un 'hacker'
que amenaza con intervenir tus dispositivos,
puedes contactarme y yo haré una revisión exhaustiva
de tus dispositivos".
Y luego fui a almorzar.
(Risas)
Después de 10 mil retuits,
sin querer, había empezado un proyecto.
Cada mañana al despertar, me encontraba con mi casilla de correo llena.
Estaba llena de historias de hombres y mujeres
que me contaban cosas horribles por las que habían pasado.
Me contactaron mujeres que eran espiadas por hombres,
hombres que eran espiados por otros hombres
y mujeres que eran espiadas por otras mujeres.
Pero la gran mayoría eran mujeres que habían sido abusadas sexualmente
por hombres que ahora las estaban espiando.
Uno de los casos más interesantes fue el de un hombre que me contactó
porque su novio le había contado a su familia coreana que era homosexual.
Una familia muy conservadora.
Así que esto no se trata solo de hombres que espían a mujeres.
Hoy estoy aquí para compartir mi experiencia y lo que aprendí.
Lo que aprendí es que la información se filtra.
Es como el agua.
Llega a lugares que no quieren que llegue.
Los seres humanos filtran.
Sus amigos comparten información suya.
Su familia da información sobre Uds.
Van a una fiesta
y alguien los etiqueta por haber estado allí.
Esta es una de las formas en que los abusadores
encuentran información que no queremos compartir con ellos.
Los abusadores, por lo general, recogen información de la víctima
preguntando a los amigos y familiares con la excusa de estar preocupados
por su "salud mental".
Una de las formas en que se filtra información
es cuando se compromete una cuenta.
Una cuenta de Gmail,
de Twitter,
de Instagram,
de iCloud, la ID de Apple,
de Netflix, de TikTok...
Tuve que aprender qué era un TikTok.
Si es necesario iniciar sesión, la cuenta queda comprometida.
Eso es porque el abusador no es siempre el abusador.
Es común en las parejas que se compartan las contraseñas.
Los que son muy íntimos y saben mucho del otro
pueden adivinar las preguntas de seguridad del otro.
O pueden mirar su código para desbloquear el celular.
Con frecuencia, tienen acceso físico al móvil o a la computadora portátil.
Y eso les da la posibilidad de manipular las cuentas de otros,
lo cual es muy peligroso.
La buena noticia es que puedo darles consejos
sobre cómo aumentar la seguridad de sus cuentas.
Un consejo que seguramente han escuchado es el siguiente:
Tengan contraseñas difíciles y únicas para todas sus cuentas.
Den respuestas difíciles y únicas a las preguntas de seguridad.
Así, si alguien sabe el nombre de su mascota de la infancia,
no podrá restablecer la contraseña.
Por último, usen el nivel más alto de autenticación en dos pasos
con el que se sientan más cómodos.
De modo que si un abusador logra robar su contraseña, no podrá entrar a su cuenta
porque le faltará completar un paso.
Otra cosa que deben hacer es mirar el apartado de seguridad
y privacidad de sus cuentas.
La mayoría tiene un apartado de seguridad y privacidad
que dice en qué dispositivos está abierta la sesión y desde dónde.
Por ejemplo, aquí estoy yo en mi cuenta de Facebook desde La Quinta,
donde estamos ahora,
y si, por ejemplo, mirando los inicios de sesión,
veo que alguien entró desde Dubái, me llamaría la atención
porque hace un tiempo no voy a Dubái.
En algunos casos, puede ser alguien que quiera espiar
a través de una herramienta de acceso remoto.
En esencia, cuando hablamos de software de vigilancia,
hablamos de herramientas de acceso remoto.
La razón por la que el gobierno quiere tener acceso completo
a sus dispositivos es la misma por la que quieren hacerlo
las parejas abusivas o exparejas.
Llevamos con nosotros dispositivos de rastreo todo el día.
Llevamos dispositivos que tienen todas nuestras contraseñas,
todas nuestras comunicaciones, hasta las más encriptadas.
Todos nuestros correos electrónicos, nuestros contactos,
nuestras selfis y nuestra información financiera
están en un solo lugar.
Así, tener acceso completo al celular de una persona
es lo más cercano a tener acceso completo a la mente de una persona.
Lo que hacen los software de vigilancia justamente es permitir ese acceso.
Se preguntarán cómo funcionan.
Un software de vigilancia es un programa disponible comercialmente
que un abusador compra
e instala en el dispositivo al que quiere acceder
porque tiene acceso físico a él.
También puede engañar a su víctima y hacer que lo instale diciéndole:
"Es muy importante que instales este programa en tu dispositivo".
Luego, el abusador le paga a la empresa que desarrolla el software
para acceder a un portal que le brinda información
sobre ese dispositivo.
Por lo general, se pagan 40 dólares al mes.
Este tipo de espionaje es bastante barato.
¿Estas empresas saben
que sus herramientas se utilizan para abusar de la privacidad?
Totalmente.
Si miran la publicidad de Cocospy, uno de estos productos,
dice en su página web
que Cocospy te permite espiar a tu esposa sin problemas
y que no debes preocuparte por los lugares o las páginas web que visita
ni con quién habla.
Da miedo.
HelloSpy, otro de esos productos,
basa su publicidad en el predominio de la infidelidad en las parejas
y la importancia de desenmascarar a tu pareja si te engaña.
Incluso tienen la foto de un hombre
que acaba de descubrir a su pareja y la ha golpeado.
Ella tiene un ojo morado, y sangre en la cara.
No creo que quepa duda sobre la posición de HelloSpy en este caso en particular
ni a quién va dirigido su producto.
Al parecer, es muy difícil saber
si se tiene uno de estos programas instalados
en la computadora o en el teléfono.
Una de las razones es que las empresas desarrolladoras de antivirus
no los reconocen como una amenaza.
No los reconocen como troyanos ni como otro tipo de amenaza
por las que generalmente alertan.
Estos son algunos de los resultados de VirusTotal a principios de este año.
En una de las muestras que analicé,
7 de 60 de las plataformas
reconoció el software de vigilancia que yo estaba probando.
Aquí hay otra donde reconoció 10 de 61.
Sigue siendo un resultado muy malo.
He logrado convencer a algunas empresas de antivirus
para que reconozcan estos programas como una amenaza.
Así que, si quieren saber si tienen instalado un software de vigilancia
en su computadora,
deben descargar el programa y escanear su equipo.
Les avisará que hay un programa no deseado en el dispositivo.
Les dará la opción de eliminarlo manualmente, pero no automáticamente.
Y eso ocurre por la manera en que se maneja el abuso.
Por lo general, la víctima no sabe si detener el acceso es lo mejor,
porque, de esa manera, el abusador se daría cuenta.
O bien le preocupa que pueda ponerse agresivo
o aún más violento si ya lo era.
Kaspersky fue una de las primeras empresas en comprometerse y tomar esto en serio.
En noviembre de este año, lanzaron un informe
según el cual, desde que empezaron a rastrear estos softwares en sus usuarios,
habían visto un aumento del 35 %.
Lookout también lanzó un comunicado diciendo que iban a comprometerse más.
Y, por último, una compañía llamada Malwarebytes lanzó el mismo comunicado
e informó que encontraron 2500 programas que podían considerarse de vigilancia.
Para finalizar,
en noviembre, ayudé a lanzar una coalición contra los softwares espías
compuesta por académicos,
gente que hace este tipo de cosas 'in situ',
profesionales que ayudan a escapar de la violencia de pareja
y empresas que desarrollan antivirus.
Nuestro propósito es tanto educar a la gente sobre estos programas,
como convencer a las empresas de antivirus de cambiar las reglas
y actuar contra estos programas siniestros.
De modo que si dentro de un año vuelvo a hablarles de esto,
pueda decirles que el problema está resuelto,
y lo único que tienen que hacer es descargar cualquier antivirus,
y que la detección de estos softwares es algo normal
Esa es mi esperanza.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)